>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Abby Nolan: I am thrilled
to introduce Kate Beaton whose
web comic Hark A Vagrant began
about 2 -- 10 years ago sorry
and is widely adored by those
who love history, literature
and silliness.
They have been collected
in best-selling volume
and rightly praised by NPR
as smart, charming and weird.
She has recently turned her
attention to children's books.
Last year was the Princess
and the Pony,
which told of how Princess
Pinecone brought
out the cuddly side of
a bunch of warriors.
Her new book is King Baby.
This baby is loved,
adored and catered to,
but spoiler alert it looks
like he will have to hand
over his crown to Queen Baby.
Kate Beaton will be
signing books at 1 p.m.,
but before she talks I wanted
to give her this special braille
edition from the Library of Congress
of the Princess and the Pony.
And please help me welcome her all
the way from Canada Kate Beaton.
[ Applause ]
>> Kate Beaton: Oh my God,
this is so exciting I was --
she was holding it and I was
wondering what it was, so beautiful.
Oh and it feels amazing,
that's lovely.
Thank you so much.
Yes, hi my name's Kate, I came all
the way from Canada to see you guys.
I hugged my polar bear
goodbye and got in the plane.
And let me see now we've
got a lot of adults here.
Can I see how many kids are in the
audience, can I get some hands up?
Some kids, all right some
kids yes, perfect, perfect.
Well you guys we're going to
read King Baby and I need --
when we read King Baby and I'm sorry
there's too many adults here you're
going to have to help out.
I need kids especially, but
I need a few adults here.
We have to put on our
best king voice
because King Baby narrates the book.
And in the very beginning
and the very end you have
to shout out with me the lines.
The last line is a surprise,
the first line is I am King Baby
and you have to say it like
you're the most regal person
that ever lived.
Are you ready?
I am King Baby.
>> I am King Baby.
>> Kate Beaton: That's it, you
guys sound like amazing kings.
So that's where we're
going to start off.
I am King Baby.
>> I am King Baby.
>> Kate Beaton: Yes, come
you have been waiting
for me I will give you many
blessings for King Baby is generous.
You will have smiles
and laughs and kisses.
You will have wiggles
and gurgles and coos.
But King Baby looks like he's
getting a little tired there
in the corner.
You know what happens
when babies get tired?
Oh-oh, but your king also has
many demands feed me, burp me,
change me, bounce me, carry me.
It's good to be the king.
That is a direct copy of
my sister's living room,
including all of their stuff.
Now bring me the thing.
What is King Baby really saying?
Oh honey, he wants his toy.
Oh but there are two toys.
Here you go champ.
Not this thing the other thing,
bring me the other thing.
Oh is my little baby
a cranky pants today?
These subjects are fools.
King Baby must be do
something bold and new.
King Baby will get
the thing himself.
Yes, King Baby can do it.
King Baby will get the thing.
Nothing will stop King Baby.
Oh he's getting there.
Oh honey, look he's crawling.
Crawling of course, but why stop
at crawling King Baby will
walk and talk and more.
Yes, his future is glory for King
Baby is no longer a baby he must
become a big boy.
But what of these poor subjects
who are they without a king
and who will lead them if not I.
We've got big new.
Are you ready this is where
I need your help again?
I am Queen Baby.
>> I am Queen Baby.
>> Kate Beaton: Yes,
that's King Baby.
He's a little tyrant,
but we love him.
I dedicated that book to my
nephew Malcolm who came in
and he was our King Baby and
everything that he did was amazing,
he's just a regular baby.
He's like fine, but we were
like he's a genius and like look
at the way he looks at
you he knows things.
He can say my name almost and I'm
just like Malcolm just, you know,
he'll be like di-di
[phonetic], oh it's close enough.
He's clearly Einstein.
You know, so I thought it
was funny to think of a book
where a baby actually had
its own internal monologue
because we're always trying
to figure what they say.
We're always like what's
he trying to --
what's he thinking,
what's he trying to say.
And my mom was really
bad for it she was
like Malcolm is thinking
this for sure.
I'm like Malcolm doesn't even know
like his two hands
are different things.
But it's nice that we like ascribe
these like giant personalities
to people who haven't even
figured things out yet.
So King Baby is a little tyrant.
Now what I'd like to do after I
read the books because we have a lot
of fun reading books is -- oh
there's goes somebody, goodbye.
Running. I'd like to draw together.
I think you guys were
drawing with Brendan,
were you guys here
with Brendan as well?
That was a lot of fun and I'd
like to do the same thing.
So I'm going to pull this back.
I'm going to tell -- do any kids
want to come up on the stage
and we could draw together?
Oh please come up, there's
lots of room up here.
And I'm going to need your guys'
suggestions, please come up.
Anybody, anybody who likes to.
On the stage is all
right depending on --
unless there's like a capacity
issue, unless we're all going
to like sink the boat which I
don't think we're going to do.
I'm going to pull this
back, so we're all going to.
Hey you guys.
Oh my God, what an
awesome bunch of kids.
Oh my God, I was so worried
I saw a lot of adults,
but all the kids were just
hiding because they're small.
Okay, we're going to draw
some things together.
Do you guys want to learn
how to draw King Baby?
It's pretty easy.
I think you guys -- if you go home
after this you're going to nail it
because King Baby is
pretty easy to draw,
so that'll be our first drawing
if I can figure this marker
our which is childproof.
I'll pull it back even more
so that you can all see.
Okay, hello you've
got a festival map.
All right, so King
Baby is very easy.
What shape is King Baby?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
He's basically an oval,
he looks like an egg.
So King Baby here we go
here's an egg, an egg shape.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, just like you know a person
without arms and legs or a body.
Do you know why I don't draw arms
and legs on King Baby at first
because he's all wrapped up,
he's wrapped up in a blanket
or in his clothes or
in a sleepy sack.
So then I draw a line across here.
So we know where King Baby's
body stops and his head starts.
And then I draw two little eyes,
one dot eye and one dot eye.
Now how do babies let us
know when they're happy?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
They're laughing and what
about when they're sad?
>> They cry.
>> Kate Beaton: They're crying.
Babies' emotions are
pretty black-and-white.
So what should we draw King Baby --
is he happy, sad, crying,
what is it?
What do you think what do you think?
>> Crying.
>> Happy.
>> Kate Beaton: Happy, happy.
Not many people pick sad,
which is totally fine.
It might be weird, do I really
want to draw a sad baby.
So I draw two big fat cheeks
and a big laughing mouth
and babies don't have teeth right,
so I just draw a big
tongue in there like that.
So that's pretty good,
that's exactly a baby
that looks like -- what's that?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah, oh I could give
him top teeth baby do --
okay we'll give him
one big old tooth.
Because it's our drawing
and we can do what we want.
And then I give King Baby
a crown and that's easy,
it's just three points,
one, two, three.
That's basically he looks like
an old man with his one tooth.
He looks kind of like my dad.
And then I draw a little something
on the clothes just to make it,
you know, we got a baby going
on here and not just an egg.
And then because he's so fancy
and regal I draw big shiny lines
because he's like a sun,
he's like the sun king
like Louis the 14th but a baby.
I love that you guys love the Louis
the 14th jokes I was [inaudible].
So that's easy you guys can do
that when you go home right,
maybe we should draw something
a bit more complicated.
Did you guys read the
Princess and the Pony?
Whoa you did, somebody did.
Well if you didn't make sure that
you find it at the library --
no you don't have to make sure
you read what you want to read.
But in the Princess and the Pony I
got to design all kinds of warriors
and that was a really fun
part of making that book.
And when we design a character we
have to figure out all the things.
What they're wearing from
their head to their toes
and it tells us a lot
about who they are.
So if you're designing
a character that's
like a warrior say first we have
to decide is this a boy
warrior or a girl warrior.
What do you guys think?
>> Girl.
>> Kate Beaton: Well yeah, let's go
with someone who hasn't
answered yet.
What about over here.
>> A girl.
>> Kate Beaton: A girl, a girl
okay, it's a girl, it's a girl.
And so I'm going to give her --
there's her face and
eyes always have
to be looking at something right.
Unless they're looking
in different directions
and then you know something
is wrong.
And then I give her tough
eyebrows, tough eyebrows
because she's a tough warrior.
And a real toothy smile all right.
So there we go.
Now what kind of -- so we got
to choose all the way
from head to the feet.
What kind of hat?
>> A girl hat.
>> Kate Beaton: A girl hat.
That sounds good.
Well actually you know you have
a really nice bow in your hair.
>> With like a flower.
>> Kate Beaton: With a
flower on it amazing.
Okay, this warrior is looking --
okay this warrior has got a
flower and a bow in her hair.
It's all right, warriors can
basically wear whatever they want.
So that's good, so she's
got a flower and a bow.
And then what kind of
hair does she have?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
What's that?
>> Girl hair.
>> Kate Beaton: Girl hair.
This is really -- you
guys are tough.
What do you think?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
What's that?
>> Loose hair.
>> Kate Beaton: Loose
hair okay, okay cool.
Actually you know what yours is
kind of like half loose and half.
So maybe we'll go with that
because that's a good look.
So she's got half up
and half down and some
of these pigtails just like you.
All right, all right
she's looking --
she's got nothing protecting
her head really except
for her own bravery
that's totally fine.
She can go in the battlefield
wearing whatever she wants.
What do warriors wear
maybe on their chest?
What do you think?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
A what?
Oh I'm sorry I can't hear you.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Armor, knight armor
awesome yes, perfect.
Okay, so she's got some armor on.
Armor on the front here, got
some clips, we got some --
like a breast plate kind of deal.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
A belly, she should have a belly.
There we go.
Because she works out, but she also
likes to eat like cool snacks so.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah for sure.
Okay, okay cool, cool,
cool got a belt.
She got -- what does a warrior
have in their hand maybe?
>> A sword.
>> Kate Beaton: A sword,
a sword is a good one.
All right, so she's got muscles
because she does cross-fit
and stuff.
She's always working out.
>> Now we need [inaudible].
>> Kate Beaton: We do need
legs you're totally right.
We've only got one arm so far,
so maybe we'll work on
that other arm first.
And here's a sword,
what kind of sword,
what kind of sword do you think?
You don't know?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
A diamond sword.
Oh what does that mean
a diamond sword?
It means it really like --
I guess okay, okay I guess you
can just draw diamonds on it.
Maybe like that
Diamonds are the sharpest
rocks aren't they?
No, what's the sharpest rock?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
A shark.
[ Laughter ]
Whoa there, she's got diamonds on
the sword and looks pretty tough.
Okay, so okay we've got
one hand, one muscly arm.
We do need the other hand.
Well maybe she's hungry.
What kind of snacks that
awesome belly should be eating?
>> How about applesauce?
>> Kate Beaton: Applesauce cool.
All right, all right applesauce.
Do you guys like applesauce?
>> Yeah.
>> Kate Beaton: I love applesauce.
That's a favorite thing
to get in your lunchbox.
There's another big arm, this
one's bigger than the other one
because she works it out more.
Why not, it's so easy
to draw sideways.
All right, cool she's got
that, she's got a jar,
a whole jar of applesauce.
And she's so strong
that she's squeezing it
and that's how she opens
it, the top popped off.
And there's a picture of an apple
on it so we know what it is.
>> Applesauce.
>> Kate Beaton: Right,
you can do anything
after you have a real
healthy snack like that right.
You can go out and you
can like win any game,
win any race, win any battle.
Okay, cool now I've
got sword, applesauce.
>> She needs some legs.
>> Kate Beaton: She
does need some legs.
>> Legs.
>> Kate Beaton: Legs okay, what
kind of legs, what do you think?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Boots, boots is a good idea.
What else do you guys think?
We'll get some suggestions
down here.
What do you think?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
High heels, high heeled
boots, she's terrifying.
That terrifies me.
Okay, big legs.
All right, big legs, big
obviously muscly legs right,
with some high heeled boots
on, more muscle lines.
That's how you draw muscles
you guys you just draw a bunch
of lines bubbling out.
All right, cool so she's
got these awesome like.
>> Put a bow on it.
>> Kate Beaton: Put a bow
on it I will, no problem.
If she can run in those
she's doing really good.
I have to wear flat shoes I can't
do that, but she's a warrior
and she's really tough and she can
do whatever she wants basically.
>> Make it sparkly.
>> Kate Beaton: Make it
sparkly how do I do that?
Let's see oh.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Do some dots, dots that's
right, sparkly, sparkly boots.
>> Make her have rosy cheeks.
>> Kate Beaton: Rosy cheeks
oh and that's a good idea.
Oh come on it is.
>> It looks like she
has [inaudible].
>> Kate Beaton: It could
be either rosy cheeks
or scars it doesn't matter.
Scars are tough though,
scars are cool right.
Let's give her a scar why
not dink, dink that's cool.
She's seen a lot in her day.
So these are sparkly.
What else -- okay now
we're at the part
where like we've got the whole
body, but we can add anything
that we want, anything at all.
So let's get some suggestions
what do you think?
>> Lightning.
>> Kate Beaton: Lightning wicked.
Okay, cool.
Actually I've got a
few colors around here.
They're so generous they've given
us blue and brown and orange.
>> Not orange.
>> Kate Beaton: Not
orange, you think?
>> Yeah.
>> Kate Beaton: Yeah okay,
orange is best for the lightning.
Sometimes when you have
a limited pallet you got
to do whatever feels best.
Where's my like person with this?
Okay, okay cool lighting.
Yeah, maybe she commands lightning
with her sword you
never know, it's like.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Now what else, what else?
Put polka dots on the chest
plate that's a good idea too
because she's kind of blank
like she's got no designs
on her like stuff here.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
I could color in the bow and
then she matches amazing.
Make her sweaty is that what I
said -- is that what I heard?
>> Look like a warrior?
>> Kate Beaton: What's that?
>> [Inaudible] sweats.
>> Kate Beaton: Sweats?
Oh like because she's
working out so hard.
Oh man, she's like yeah --
well I'm sweating right now is
that why you said that?
I really feel like -- these
spotlights are really hot.
You think we did a good job there?
>> Yeah.
>> Kate Beaton: You
think we like -- yeah?
Okay cool, good, good.
We can keep on drawing.
Actually and you know
what maybe we have some --
maybe some of the grown-ups in
the audience have questions.
Maybe you guys have
questions, do you have questions
about being an author or an
artist or anything like that?
Yes.
>> How many books did you write?
>> Kate Beaton: How
many books did I write?
I have written two picture books,
including the one we
just read King Baby
and another one called
the Princes and the Pony.
And then I have written some
awful comic strips for grown-ups.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
So I think.
They're not awful I
enjoyed writing them.
What is your question?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Have I written any
chapter books, no?
Are you reading chapter
books already?
Oh my, you are too.
Oh my God, you guys are so.
These are in some advances
stages no wonder you're
at the National Book Festival.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Did I like to illustrate
when I was younger?
Yes I did, I liked it very much.
I used to draw every day and that's
basically how I knew that I wanted
to be an artist because your
favorite things you try to do them
as much as you can right.
I did the same thing.
>> My favorite thing is drawing.
>> Kate Beaton: Your
favorite thing is drawing.
You might be up here someday
drawing wicker warriors.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
What's that?
>> I'm writing books.
>> Kate Beaton: You're
writing books.
Oh man, how many books
have you written?
How many are you thinking
about writing?
>> A million.
>> Kate Beaton: A million cool that
sounds like a reasonable number.
Yes.
>> Do you like writing
or reading better?
>> Kate Beaton: Oh do I like
writing or reading better.
See that's a hard question
because I think that I --
whatever I am doing at the
time is what I like the best.
So if I'm reading a really
good book that's what I
like better than anything.
And if I'm drawing or
writing something on my own,
that's what I like
doing at that time.
You make time for all
the things you like.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
The diamonds what?
The diamonds look like
Harry Potter stuff.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Make them blue okay, cool.
What's your question?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
How did I become an author?
Oh it's the same way I
become an artist I knew
that I liked doing it a lot.
So I was always writing comics and
writing stories and drawing pictures
and eventually Scholastic showed up
at my doorstep and said would you
like draw a picture book, so
I said yes of course I would.
But there are a lots of different
ways that you can become an author,
but the most important thing to
do is to practice all the time.
And then -- oh hello
you're coming back up.
You just roll wherever
you got to go.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
My favorite author.
Oh my God, that's so hard, that's
so hard that changes all the time.
I don't know I like Maurice
Sendak do you like him,
Where the Wild Things are?
That's a very good book.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
[Inaudible] at their house.
>> What's your favorite dad?
>> Kate Beaton: What's
my favorite dad?
>> Yes.
>> Kate Beaton: My dad.
Is your favorite dad your dad?
>> Yeah.
>> Kate Beaton: Cool, I thought so.
Yes.
>> Can you give the
drawing to somebody?
>> Kate Beaton: Can I give
the drawing to somebody?
I probably do.
These guys probably know.
Somebody probably knows, we'll
find that out afterwards.
Do you guys have any
questions here on the side?
Do you have -- would you
like to say anything?
No, you guys are such good
listeners this whole time.
What about you guys?
Do you have any questions or
anything you'd like to say?
>> No.
>> Kate Beaton: No.
This is the quiet section over here.
>> No.
>> Kate Beaton: No okay, but
you have another question?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
What's that?
>> Do you like Harry Potter?
>> Kate Beaton: Do I
like Harry Potter I do.
I think that you do, I have
a gut feeling that you do.
That's good because
that's a really great book.
Maybe there's some questions
from the grown-ups back here
before we send everybody home.
Somebody over there.
Oh somebody here, oh a question from
the quiet corner I'm so excited.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
What's that you have a question?
>> My grandmother has
one [inaudible].
>> Kate Beaton: Oh your grandmother
has one of the big post-it thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Kate Beaton: Why
does she have that?
I'm not saying I don't believe you.
It's cool, that's cool.
You guys are the best, you
guys are such good readers.
Maybe why don't we take
some audience questions
from the grown-ups here you
guys can make your way back
to your moms and dads down there.
Oh one question here from somebody
who didn't have one before.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
She needs a what?
She needs a big scar or scarf?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
A what?
>> A blue [inaudible].
>> Kate Beaton: A blue skirt.
Oh man okay, a blue skirt let's
do it before this all ends.
It's true there's not
like going on right here,
so we got to like jazz it up right.
Nice.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Well sometimes, I mean she's
not naked it's pants so.
But we can like yeah.
She's modest, she's a modest gal.
>> She's pretty.
>> Kate Beaton: She
is pretty I agree.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
She says I can draw better than
you can, but look there are a lot
of people that can draw a lot
better than me and that's a fact.
But you know what there
is some things --
here's my advice to
you about drawing.
There are some things
that I was really good
at drawing when I was your age.
I was really good at drawing cats,
I was very bad at drawing cars.
I'll answer this -- I'll
keep telling my story
and then I will totally
listen to your question.
So I was good drawing at some things
and bad drawing at other things
and they used to make me a
little bit sad because I wanted
to be good at everything.
I didn't really, you know, it
sucks to be bad at something.
But then I realized after
a while that I don't mind
that I'm not very good
at drawing cars,
I'm still not very
good at drawing cars.
But I do draw picture
books and I get
to draw all the pictures
that I want.
So I just focus on the things that I
like to draw and that make me happy
and I don't worry about the
things that I find more difficult
or that I don't like to draw.
You can draw whatever you want
as long as you're enjoying it.
What's your question?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Color the belt brown a good idea.
Okay, we only have a few minutes
so we're going to actually --
there's a few people at the
microphone so we're going
to get them to ask questions.
>> Hello.
>> Kate Beaton: Hello.
>> So what is because you do a lot
of literature and history
[inaudible]?
>> Kate Beaton: Yeah.
>> So what's your favorite
to like make fun of, to
go back to, you know?
>> Kate Beaton: Oh to make fun,
it's always the funnest to make fun
of if you're doing like
parity history or literature,
anything that takes
itself too seriously.
Any like overblown figures
who are too powerful
and were never really
checked in their time.
It's always fun to go back
and just destroy them.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Color what?
Color the what?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
The white, the lightning,
the lightning,
color the lightning in okay.
I'll do that a little
bit we're going to --
if anybody else wants to
come up to the microphone
with a question while
I'm doing this.
>> Hello.
>> Kate Beaton: Hello.
>> You write about your family
a lot, especially on your.
>> Kate Beaton: Yes I do.
>> Kate Beaton: Twitter feed.
How do they react to being in
cartoons, do you ever get flack
like I don't look like
that or I [inaudible]?
>> Kate Beaton: They don't mind.
I don't think my parents know how
many twitter followers I have,
which is really handy for me.
But they're aware of it
and they're very proud.
They don't really understand what
I do sometimes, but they're very,
very good sports about that.
As long as nobody bothers them
like at the grocery store
they're totally fine.
Yes.
>> Hello.
>> Kate Beaton: Hello.
>> What's your nephew
thing of King Baby?
>> Kate Beaton: My nephew he sat
on it and he bent some of the pages
and he saw where there was a
picture of a cat and that was --
he's two, he turned
two yesterday so that's
about as far as we got with him.
One more question?
Yes.
>> I love Hark A Vagrant.
>> Kate Beaton: Thank you.
>> And I love how you -- am
I really close to the mic?
I love how you made some
books that are really sad
and depressing, hilarious.
My question is.
>> Kate Beaton: I don't
believe that.
>> Are there any books that you
wanted to draw a comic about
or figures you want to
draw a character about,
then you just realize that they
made you too sad or [inaudible]?
>> Kate Beaton: Oh yeah
for sure, for sure.
There's always like people that
you really admire their story
as a historical figure
or something like that.
But you want to respect
their story as well.
And sometimes, you know, the people
that we admire the most just
had a really, really hard life
and it's hard to make fun of that,
it's hard to pull something out of
that that seems disrespectful
of their struggle.
So there have been times, but you
know there's always other heroes
and villains to put your focus on.
So we only have a few
minutes, thank you.
We only have a few minutes.
You guys thank you so much
you were really wonderful.
Are we happy with our drawing?
Is there any one last, is
there like a [inaudible]?
So what do you think,
what do you guys think?
A kiss, oh that was just what I did.
Yes.
>> I think you should
put [inaudible] socks.
>> Kate Beaton: Some socks.
Hey, that's a great idea.
Cool and then we'll make
them orange so that we.
That's very fashion forward
the socks coming out like that.
Yes okay.
>> Maybe you should
color [inaudible].
>> Maybe I should color in her bow.
You guys you just out stuff
while we have a few more --
we got about one minute,
one hot minute.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Color what?
[Inaudible] color?
>> Color that part in.
>> Kate Beaton: Okay,
I will color this part
in that was very frustrating
for you with OCD.
>> Hi, I have a question for you.
>> Kate Beaton: Yes, go ahead.
>> If you can talk.
>> Kate Beaton: Go ahead.
>> So you've obviously just
accomplished King Baby,
which was a fantastic book and.
>> Kate Beaton: Thank you yes.
>> I was wondering what's next?
>> Kate Beaton: What's next?
>> If you can even think
about what's next for you.
>> Kate Beaton: Right now I'd
love to do another kids' book
and I'd love to do a book
where someone else wrote
and I drew the pictures.
But I mean we'll see.
I'm working on a memoir
about working
in an oil sands working
camp right now.
These kids are going
to love that one.
All right, you guys
we're all done here.
So thank you so much.
Thank you guys, you were the best,
thank you for helping me out.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at LOC.gov.